Know your stuff, practice, and then just
do it and be there. My name is Matt
Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business. Welcome to Think
Fast, Talk Smart, the podcast.
>> [music]
>> Today I'm really excited to speak with
Kai Ryssdal. Kai is the host and senior
editor of Marketplace, an Emmy and
Peabody award-winning daily show where
he translates complex economic and
business news into engaging, accessible
conversations for [music] millions of
listeners. Before Marketplace, Kai spent
8 years in the United States Navy and
later served as a member of the United
States [music] Foreign Service. He's
renowned for his signature
conversational delivery and deep
economic expertise. So, welcome Kai.
>> Thank you.
>> I am a big listener to your show. I
enjoy it every day and I a big thank you
to Mary Beth Kushner and J.J. Your for
the introduction. Thanks for being here.
>> I'm I'm absolutely plea- pleased to.
>> Okay, shall we get started?
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Uh you've got a unique gift
of making sense of a lot of really
complex, detailed information.
A lot of the people listening in are in
similar situations where they have
technical, financial, scientific
information they have to get across. How
do you think about making that content
accessible?
>> It's important to understand that I am
not a business and economics guy. I'm a
history and political science guy from
way back, right? I have not taken
economics course number one in college
or in graduate school. Um and until I
got the job at Marketplace, um I hadn't
really given it much thought. So, when I
sit down and and this holds true for my
entire time at Marketplace, when I sit
down to write the show, I do two things.
I have to make him make sense to myself
what I'm saying, right? So, obviously I
have to do some research and understand
what it is and then figure out how I'm
going to explain it and then and this is
the God's honest truth, um I think about
how I would help my mother understand
it. My mom is an 86-year-old woman who,
this is true, does not have an ATM card.
Goes to the bank every Friday afternoon
and cashes a check for $100 to tide her
over till next Friday. Um so if I can
make it make sense to her
uh then I think I'm doing all right. The
caveat and the catch with that of course
is that
we have really sophisticated listeners
to Marketplace, right? We have folks who
work on Wall Street. We have folks who
work in the industry. We have folks who
work in
every possible slice of this economy and
they understand in depth the things that
I'm talking about. So make it
understandable but don't dumb it down.
That's the challenge.
>> Right. Are there particular techniques
that you rely on? Analogies, stories?
>> Just a a turn of phrase. This is sort of
overly simplistic but radio audio,
uh video aside, right? Cuz that's where
podcasts are going or already are, um is
a distinctly aural medium. And so it has
to resonate with people. It has to It
has to come off my tongue in a way that
I know what I'm talking about and then
it has to land with them in a way that
they're going to be able to absorb it so
that they're not
trying to process the thing I just said
while they're listening to the thing I'm
saying now. So it's a little bit of word
play, it's a little bit of humor, it's a
little bit of self-deprecation and then
the nuts and bolts, right?
>> And you're so good at doing that. I I
really appreciate this idea that it's
not just landing what you're saying in
the moment
but you don't want it to distract them
from what comes next.
>> audio and print, right? When I'm reading
a a newspaper article or a magazine
article, if I realize that I've blipped
out for a second and I can't remember
what this guy's name is, I can scroll
back. Can't really do that You can do
that on a podcast but you know, in
broadcast audio you can't and and if you
have to do it on a podcast and in
digital audio, you're kind of breaking
the rhythm, you know?
>> Yeah, there is a rhythm to it and you're
very good at keeping things moving.
There's there's a there's a flow to the
work you do. Are you conscious of that?
>> Oh yeah, very much so. Very much so.
>> Tell me more about that.
>> My job is to make everybody who's there
at the beginning of the program or the
beginning of the podcast or the
beginning of whatever I'm doing still be
there at the end. So, you you weave that
through the program. You make references
to things you have said or are going to
say. Um you talk about things that are
coming up. Just make people still be
there. You know, that if if you actually
listen to a 28 minute and 45 second
episode of Marketplace, which is how
much time we have.
My total content on days that don't have
a lot of interviews and me content, my
total contribution is
three [snorts] and a half, maybe four
minutes in 30 second chunks setting up
our reporters, right? So, my job is to
make those reporters stories sing and to
make people at the end of my 30 second
introduction say, "Oh wait, now I want
to hear this story." and make them hang
around for another three minutes and 30
seconds or whatever it is. Um
and so that's sort of what I do.
>> When I teach my students, I use the
analogy of being a tour guide. A good
tour guide gets people excited and keeps
them moving through it and wanting to
see what's next.
>> But doesn't give it away.
>> That's exactly right.
>> Right? Cuz if you give it away,
[clears throat] then what are you even
doing?
>> That's right. So, you have to you have
to make them curious without revealing
too much. And that and that that there's
a skill to that. Speaking of the way
your show runs, we we had Peter Sagal on
who did Wait Wait Don't Tell Me and we
talked about introductions. Many of us
are in situations where we have to
introduce people. You do a lot of
introductions just like him. Do you have
a way of introducing people that that
others could leverage?
>> So, first of all, just on my own
personal experience and for those out
there who wind up doing a lot of
introductions, don't read somebody's CV
aloud. Just don't do that. Please. It's
it's Not only is it mortifying, it's not
edifying for the audience. Um find
something personal, find an anecdote,
find something that's going to make it
stick. That that's the only thing I can
say. Make it relevant to the people
to whom this person is going to be
speaking, right? Introduce them. Make
them make friends, you know, in in as
short a period as as you have to do it.
Because that's what you have to do. And
when I'm setting up an interview, it's
me and this person for the next four
minutes, and the audience has to be
there. And if you if you don't have the
audience with you, then you've failed,
honestly, right? And look, I'm I'm a
huge fan of Peters, and and Peter does
this really well, you know, and he does
it with humor. He has the benefit,
actually, of having the live audience,
right? So, he's got he's got that
feedback mechanism. Um
but, you know, just just make people
make friends. That's it.
>> I like what you said. To me, a good
introduction, and and you hinted at
this, is it's an invitation. It's an
invitation to want to hear more. And
you're setting the other person up, and
anecdotes are great ways to do it. Uh
so, you interview a wide range of
people, from Fortune 500 CEOs to a a
small business owner.
And your interviews often feel very
conversational, not very threatening.
How do you work to make that
conversation happen? It feels like
people are are just talking to you, even
though there many, many people listening
in.
>> So, this is a methodology, Weston,
right?
>> Yes.
>> Obviously, there's a team of producers
at Marketplace, uh
who
do the booking of the interview. They'll
do, sometimes, an initial conversation
with that person. Uh
and then, sometimes, uh you know,
actually think about the questions they
want to ask. And they give me,
basically, a one sheet. And they say,
"Listen, this is why we're going to do
this person. Here are my thoughts on
this, and here's a couple of questions."
I take that, and I internalize it. Uh
and then I put it away.
And I I will not go into a studio with a
list of questions in front of me. I will
have major points and things that really
need to be said, especially if it's a
big deal interview. Like, if I'm talking
to J. Powell, you know, there's some
things I have to ask him, and and I'll
note those down.
But but the name of the game
is to be there. And and by being there,
I mean you have to listen. Because we
can all hear when an interviewer is
literally running down a list of
questions, and has not paid attention to
the answer preceding the next question,
and just moves right on. And that makes
me crazy. So, so be there. Be in the
moment. Make it a conversation. Uh Uh
understand that you are in charge and
you have to guide this person to where
you want them to be,
but it can't be just ticking through a
list of questions, right? And sometimes
the best question is an interrogatory.
Tell me more about that. Oh? Or
sometimes if it's a newsmaker who's
blowing you off, come on, really? Just
be there and be yourself.
>> Yeah, and and connect what they're
saying to what what's important for you
and
>> Right.
>> And go ahead
>> has a very specific purpose, right? Our
purpose is to raise the economic
intelligence of the country. And so,
what you will hear in my interviews
versus an interview that you hear on
other shows or other podcasts is me
going with that lens, right? Let's let's
figure out what the economic slice of it
is, what the business slice of this is,
and help people understand that part of
what it is
that they're going to consume in the
news that day. I'm incredibly conscious
of that because that's our bread and
butter, right? Our bread and butter is
business and the economy as a lens to
see the world.
And and that's what I do every day when
I go into the studio.
>> So, having a clear focus of what the
goal is, the larger goal, being present
and listening, and knowing that it's not
just the questions you ask, but it's the
responses to the question that keep it
conversation.
>> It's entirely the responses to the
questions, right? Because the person
you're talking to has to feel that they
are in a conversation with you. If they
feel they're on the spot or they're just
answering wrote questions, then their
answers change. That's death to a to a
decent interview, and it's 4 minutes
that my mom's going to turn off the
radio.
>> How do you keep an interview on track?
Sometimes people wander or they don't
want to answer the question you you ask.
>> do. Well,
so that's so that's two different
things. If they don't want to answer the
question you asked, you have to ask the
question again. And what I will not
infrequently do is after I've asked
question A, they will give me answer X,
right? And I will say in these many
words,
let me try this again and see if I can
get a different answer, right? So, that
they know that, number one, I'm not
satisfied with what they said, right?
But, number two, maybe they'll frame
things in a slightly different way. A
really experienced CEO is going to stick
to their knitting and and give you the
stock answer. Somebody who's, you know,
regular walk of life or running a small
business or what have you, is going to
probably recirculate. And then, the
other thing is, you know, if if they
don't tell you what you need to know,
you have to keep going at it, right? If
it's an important thing, if it's an
important interview,
you have to get that information out
there because that's what the listener
demands.
>> And when somebody goes off track or on a
tangent, how do you pull them back?
>> got to interrupt them sometimes, right?
Sometimes you have to say, "Listen,
let's put a pin in that conversation and
let's bring it back here to to this
other thing, right?" Also, if you're
doing a live interview, it's one thing,
but if you're doing a taped interview,
you have the power of the razor blade
and the splicing tape, you know, and you
can you can sort of save them from
themselves.
>> One of the techniques I like to use when
things get off a a little off on a
tangent is is to interrupt. I totally
agree. But, I do so with a paraphrase
where I'll highlight something that
they've said and then pull it back
>> Right. Totally.
>> But, again, it comes back to that being
that tour guide where you know where you
want to go. And if we start going off,
we got to pull
>> And and the catch, of course, is finding
that moment, right? Because you don't
want to be rude, you don't want to
really interrupt them, uh but it's your
job to keep the train on the tracks, for
sure.
>> And and the the rudeness piece, I think,
is a really important point. When you're
you don't want to be rude to the guest,
but you're being rude to the other
people, the audience, if you don't do
it. So, so you've got to weigh those.
>> Zoom, where conversations turn into
results.
Hi, Matt here. We all know how valuable
Zoom can be for our conversations, our
meetings, for connecting.
But, now Zoom puts your tasks on
autopilot with their new Zoommate.
Zoom analyzes, learns, and acts on your
conversations to help you complete your
work, like building a deck, drafting a
proposal, logging a ticket, updating
your CRM. All of this is done
automatically, but at your discretion.
Most work platforms help you
communicate. Some help you organize, but
Zoom turns conversations
into outcomes. Zoom ahead.
>> There's a lot of emotion in some of the
things that you talk about, anxiety in
particular, you know, when we're talking
about economics, what's going on in the
world.
How do you thread that needle of of
acknowledging the emotion, the anxiety
in the moment, but also not getting
people so upset and and fearful that
they tune out?
>> We had this conversation a lot in the
early days of the financial crisis going
on now 20 years ago.
Cuz the news, much as it is today, was
really, really grim. And it was it was
economically and financially scary. And
our conversation was
what's our job? Is our job to make
people feel better, or is our job to
help them understand what's happening,
and then they can process it how they
want? And we came down on, we have to
help them understand this, right? And we
can't sugarcoat it. So, let's address
the anxiety. Let's address the fact that
these are scary, scary times. And then
go from there with them having
the information. I had done about
probably 10 years ago now,
uh an interview with uh
the CEO of Marriott. Well, I went to New
York, went to breakfast with him in a
Marriott hotel, and we had a great
conversation. And it was really good.
Arne Sorenson, CEO of Marriott. Okay.
Formula. Anyway, early in COVID, I
discovered that he had been diagnosed
with stage four
uh cancer of some variety or other.
And it was like terminal, and he knew
that.
And so, we got him back on the show.
Because he hadn't stepped down yet, but
he was clearly dying. And we did it on
video, actually. And he looked like a
stage four cancer guy.
And we had our conversation about his
scary moment in these really scary
times.
It landed with me, it landed with
listeners, and you just have to go
there. Right? And And look, I've I've
been doing this for a while now, and I I
think listeners trust me to take them
there. I think about that interview a
lot, actually. That was a moment, right?
It was a moment, and you just you just
have to lean into it.
>> Acknowledging that there is anxiety
around this and saying we're going to
get through this together, but you're
better off understanding and
appreciating it.
>> Right.
>> And that that way people are willing to
go that distance. And I think the point
you made is that there's there's a trust
that people have in you that allows that
to happen.
I want to deal with anxiety,
specifically about anxiety you might
feel. You've been a fighter pilot, a
diplomat, you're a live on-air host. Uh
for many of us those would be
anxiety-filled situations. Do you have
some things that you do to help you
manage your anxiety that others of us
could benefit from?
>> Here is my mantra. And it makes my
producers crazy when I say this out
loud, but but it is truly what I
believe.
Um if you think about how you sound
in front of a microphone, while you're
sitting in front of a microphone, you're
going to screw up how you sound on the
microphone. So, don't think, just talk.
Okay? Now, that's not to say don't be
prepared. It's not to say don't think
about what you want to get out of it
before you go sit down in the studio.
It's not to say don't be your prepared
best, right? But once you get there,
and this goes back to the thing we're
talking about before, about being in the
conversation. Once you get there, the
only way to be there is not think about
all those other things. Just be there,
right? And have that conversation. It It
sounds silly, but but in a way that's
calming, right? Because if you know
you've done your homework before you get
into the studio, right? You don't need
that piece of paper. You don't need the
producer in that ear. Once you're there,
you have to be there.
And if you're thinking about all that
other crap, you're doing it wrong.
>> You know, a lot of my work in the last
several years has been helping people
speak in the moment and spontaneously,
and it's exactly what you're talking
about. You can do a lot to prepare.
People always sort of their head
when I say you can prepare to be
spontaneous, but it's that planning that
>> That's exact That's exactly right.
>> And then when you show up, you just do
it. It's like an athlete. Athletes do
lots of drills.
>> And And look, there are some people who
can actually not think about it and show
up and be spontaneous and be great.
That's not most people.
>> That's correct. That's correct. So, what
helps you to manage some of the fear is
that you do a lot of prep. And then you
then you just focus and
>> Then I know when I get in the room, I
know what I'm doing.
>> So, if something doesn't go the way you
want, a question doesn't come out right,
you say something that that you you
you're not happy with,
in the moment, what do you do with that?
And after the fact, what do you do with
that?
>> So, I try really hard not to fix things
after the fact, right? So, when we're
doing a taped interview and I screw
something up and I know I've screwed it
up, um I will actually correct it in the
next moment, right? The next moment I
have in that interview. Just to go back
and and be honest about it. Sometimes my
producer will be on Slack and say,
"Listen, it's 42, not 17." or whatever.
But just fix it right there, you know?
Right.
>> And not beat yourself up about it
because you can then get in your head
saying, "I can't believe I made that
mistake. I said the wrong number." Uh
you have to still be in that moment.
Mike Krzyzewski, the famous basketball
coach, um taught his players this idea
of next play. So, you screw up, you keep
going.
>> So, So, I'm a I'm a high school and a
college soccer referee.
>> Okay.
>> And it's the same deal. Because if you
don't let the mistake that you made by
not calling that foul or missing the
handball or whatever, if you don't let
that go, you will surely miss the next
one. Right? And it's a 90-minute game
and you got to be there for all 90
minutes of it. That's exactly right.
>> You're a ref, I find that really
interesting given what you do for a
profession. I see some commonalities of
that. But
absolutely, you can carry with you that
that issue. And And I That in and of
itself is a skill that's hard for people
to
>> really it's really hard. It's really
hard.
>> And there's a I I like to distinguish
between rumination and reflection. I
think reflection's really important.
That's how we learn and we grow. But if
we ruminate in that moment, it's going
to cause everything else to fall.
You ask a lot of questions. A lot of
questions.
How do you stay curious about that? I
mean, it can become sort of mundane,
[snorts]
but you you seem genuine genuinely
interested.
>> am a genuinely curious person and and
that's the rewarding part of being a
journalist, right? My job, you know,
people always say, "Well, the host's job
in a radio program is to be a, you know,
a
a stand-in for the audience and ask them
what they want to know." And and sure,
yes, to some degree, but but my job is
to be respectful of the guest and
respectful of the audience's time. And
to try to elicit from them, you know,
things that I think the audience is
going to find interesting. And the only
way to do that is to be curious about
what they do. Sometimes it's
manufactured curiosity and sometimes
it's genuine, but the name of the game
is don't let that show. Be there, ask
those questions, and hope the audience
gets something out of it.
>> And even in those manufactured moments,
there's something in there that that is
interesting.
>> Oh, yeah. There's there's always
something that makes you go, "Huh." And
then, which by the way, if you're
listening to the answer,
leads you on a different path and it
takes you off of that prepared list of
questions, right?
>> That's right. Is there a question that
you have that you go back to if you need
a question in the moment? Do you have a
a favorite or a go-to or not so much?
>> smile because me me having a me going
blank in in a big interview led to one
of the most revealing answers we've ever
had on Marketplace. But but let me give
you my go-to. My go-to for anybody is
in a business and economics situation,
"What's your worst nightmare? What keeps
you up at night?" It gives me time to
think and regroup, you know?
Um and they will sometimes the answers
are revealing and sometimes it's cutting
room floor stuff, right? Sometimes it's
good and sometimes it's not. I was
interviewing Janet Yellen once, between
her time as Fed chair and uh when she
got the job as Treasury Secretary. So,
it's like 2018-19.
We went to her office in Brookings in
Washington. When I go into those
interviews, I don't have a piece of
paper in front of me because I I like to
be there and present with the the person
I'm talking to.
And she finished whatever answer she had
given to the question, and my mind just
went blank. I just completely brain
farted.
And so I looked at her and I said, "Do
you think Donald Trump understands
economic policy?"
And she looked at me and said, "No, I
don't." And I was like, "Oh my god.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh my god, right?" It came from me just
not knowing what else to do. So I just
came up with something. So, you know,
just say something. Right?
>> The biggest fear people report to me is
the fear of blanking out. And
>> But it happens everybody, you know? I
mean
>> And the way through it is to to do what
you did. Just
>> the way through it is through it, you
know?
>> Yeah. Really interesting.
>> Before we get started, a quick reminder
to make sure you are following our show
in whatever app you're listening to.
This is the best way to help our show
grow and to make sure you never miss an
episode. And now a word from our
sponsors.
Their support helps us bring you this
show free of charge.
Over the course of my career, I've had
the privilege of working with some truly
amazing coaches. And I've also spent
years coaching others. And I can tell
you firsthand, coaching makes a real
difference. That's why I really
appreciate what strawberry.me is doing.
Strawberry.me makes coaching more
accessible, affordable, and global.
Whether you want to become a stronger
communicator, a more confident leader,
or simply more intentional in your
career, having the right coach in your
corner can make an enormous difference.
Visit strawberry.me/smart
and take 50% off of your first session.
And make sure you let them know Matt
sent you. And now, back to our
conversation.
>> I end all of my episodes with three
questions. One I'm going to make up just
for you, and the other two I've been
asking people for a long time. Are you
up for that?
>> Yeah.
>> In terms of what you do, how do you see
AI impacting communication and
journalism in general?
>> Well, so that's two different things,
right? The of communication and fakes
and all of those things is deeply
troubling not just on a journalistic
level, but on a societal level, right?
On a trust and on a mutual adherence to
norms basis, right?
I think that's that's really really
challenging. Journalism can be really
really helped by artificial
intelligence,
analysis, trend spotting, you know, all
of those things. But
AI writing articles and doing podcasts
and all of which is capable of doing is
not the way to a successful future for
the United States and for the rest of
the planet. You know, set aside the fact
that it would put me and probably you
out of a job. Absolutely. Yeah. You
know?
>> Right. So, use it as a tool.
>> It is a tool, right? But be smart and
let's have a human in that loop and
let's not just abrogate all
responsibility and say, "Here you go. AI
is going to take care of this cuz it's
not."
>> At the end of the day, communication is
operationalized critical thinking and if
we let if we let AI do that, we're
missing out on the
Question number two. Who's a
communicator that you admire and why?
>> The two that I've come up with are not
spoken word people.
>> Okay.
>> Jim Fallows,
formerly at the Atlantic, now on his own
Substack, but for many years
an observational journalist of
international affairs and national
security and a writer. I would read
almost anything he's written, truly.
Same thing goes for John Dickerson, late
of CBS News and uh and Slate. I just
find those two guys
really interesting to read. I'm really
critical of spoken word people or
television people because I'm so
innately connected to that. Part of
that's probably professional jealousy,
part of it's probably envy somehow, but
those are two who who come to the top of
my head.
>> Is there something that they do in their
writing that's particularly
>> They're they are at the same time
very concrete and very big idea And they
they have the ability to land that
plane, if you will, you know?
>> And that's that's an art to be able to
>> Oh, for sure. Yeah.
Absolutely.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Final question. What are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe?
>> Know what you're talking about.
But not to such a degree as you are
paralyzed by the information, right?
It's like you use the the recipe
thing, I will continue that analogy.
>> Right.
>> sometimes you need to pinch of salt,
sometimes you need a half tablespoon of
salt, whatever, throw some salt in
there, right? So, know what you're
talking about. Number two, some concept
of brevity.
Um
if you are long-winded, you will lose
people's attention.
Uh if you are too short-winded, you you
shortchange your listener and and the
subject at hand. So, find that happy
medium between going on too long and
just saying, "All right, let's go." And
then finally,
I'm going to go back to my old standby.
Um
don't think too much.
Know what you're talking about, right?
Item number one on this, know what
you're talking about. And then once you
know that, once you've internalized it,
then just just be in the moment and just
do it, right? Be present, be yourself,
express yourself,
and then the audience will react to you.
>> Know your stuff. Be concise.
>> Yeah.
>> And be present.
>> Excellent ingredients and
>> [music]
>> and helpful for not just what you do,
but for what all of us do. Guy, this has
been fantastic. A fan boy moment for me.
I I really enjoy your show and I enjoy
how you communicate and try to emulate
some of the things you do. Thank you for
your time and keep up the great work.
>> Absolute pleasure, Matt. Thank you.
>> Thank you for listening to another
episode of Think Fast, Talk Smart, the
podcast. To learn more about similar
communication, listen to Peter Sagal,
episode 220. This episode was produced
by Katherine Reed, [music] Ryan Campos,
and me, Matt Abrahams. Our music is from
Floyd Wonder, with special thanks to the
team at Spotify Los Angeles and Podium
Podcast Company. Please find us on
YouTube and wherever you get your
podcasts. Be sure to subscribe and rate
us. Also, follow us on LinkedIn, TikTok,
and Instagram. And check out
fastersmarter.io for deep dive videos,
English language learning content, and
our newsletter. Please consider joining
our Think Fast, Talk Smart learning
community at fastersmarter.io/learning.
You'll find video lessons, learning
quests, discussion boards, my AI coach,
and book club opportunities. Again,
that's fastersmarter.io/learning
to become part of the Think Fast, Talk
Smart learning community.